Brad Pitt told us that his love life was
a disaster but listen to him now this is
the Brad we love in love with love I had
crushes I always hear Christ just she's
very passionate because I'm addicted
where was your first kiss
her name is Lisa it was in her garage I
was pretty excited titillated his fourth
graders get it was definitely on John oh
sure but I couldn't sing for Brad is
totally candid about all his major life
moments from his love life to 80s dance
moves
I see more dance in my future even prom
night I went to two proms two proms
because I was dating a beautiful young
woman from the neighboring high school
so we had to hit one and then hit the
other blue tux white white top with
tails fresh off his Golden Globes win
Brad went to New York to present Quentin
Tarantino with an award he also stopped
by buddy Bradley Cooper's Manhattan
apartment
could they be working on a new project
together we'd love that as for how Brad
got his start in Hollywood he tells all
too W Magazine the first TV thing was
either Dallas yes sir or 30-something
where I had one line which was yes or it
was no actually Brad it was I I was
extra in the Charlie Sheen film and they
grabbed me to be like the waiter it was
a big dinner scene at a restaurant and I
felt like I'm gonna try and get a line
in and then I got to this actress at the
end and I poured her drink and then I
looked at her and I said would you like
anything else she looked at me and went
I had the first date he goes cut cut cut
cut and came over to me so you do that
again you're off to send I was like
[Music]